et s'il ya bien un endroit où l'on suit
avec attention cette course autour du
monde c'est au salon nautique qui se
tient ce week-end à paris sur place on
espère relancer le marché lui aussi
touché par la crise près de 1700 bateaux
sont présentés parmi eux bien sûr de
jolis ou alliés reportage julien
beaumont et abdel wiiware petit temps
sur l'industrie nautique au salon de
paris certains chantier affichent leur
bateau et surtout des tarifs aguicheur
il faut dire que plusieurs constructeurs
connaissent en ce moment des difficultés
salvatore serio vient de reprendre le
chantier dufour et 600 salariés ont
connu trois semaines de chômage partiel
20 millions d'euros vient d'être
injectés alors cette année opération
promotion la clientèle veut faire des
bonnes affaires
il ya la clientèle il ya des gens qui
sont un peu délaissé par la bouche et
donc ont envie de se faire plaisir mais
ils veulent faire de bronze offert le
leader mondial des voiliers aussi été
touchés le carnet de commandes s'est
essoufflé mais le constructeur n'a pas
de dettes
un compte en banque bien rempli et des
investissements prévus pour 2009
tous les secteurs ont été touchés de la
même façon parce que les clients se sont
arrêtés ils ont eu peur que le système
explose le système n'explose pas donc
les clients vont maintenant revenir dans
le bateau comme ailleurs les moins
touchés par la crise sont les fabricants
très spécialisés des niches comme ce
catamaran à 300000 euros il attire un
public de marins avec un projet bien
défini
on a beaucoup de clients grands départs
ceux qui partent année sabbatique ou en
retraite etc
et donc ces gens là peuvent avoir
tendance aussi à dire pour moi la crise
est bien gentille mais justement la
morosité allez hop on part sous les
tropiques
voilà donc c'est quand même maintenant
un tiers de notre clientèle
un salon où l'on vient aussi pour rêver
chambre à coucher avec vue sur la plage
méridienne pour profiter de l'océan un
peu d'évasion en attendant de connaître
le bilan des ventes dans dix jours